an eclectic guest list today and we cap
it off with a poll wall our street cred
just went through the roof here hey what
it do how you doing Paul Gracie again
you're killing it yeah yeah you uh kind
of went easy on the jewelry today yeah
I'm like dated a man I like like spring
jewelry you got the grill yes sir yeah
now can you eat with the grill on you
can but you know I mean it's it's high
fashion high quality jewelry like for
instance like you you watch you wouldn't
really dip you're watching a cup of
Starbucks and then dip it in some
lasagna you know yeah so it's kind of
saying well you can't eat with it but
you you know usually like proper grill
etiquette is if I matter if I'm at a
restaurant you know I won't take it out
you know but if I'm at home alone maybe
I'll take it out when I eat you know I
got a couple of quesadillas back there
you know in the dawn respect I need to
get cleaned out Ernie talking about
Irma's up street yeah man the best spot
in Houston man so I definitely went
there a few times we had to get my girl
cleaned up favorite rapper growing up
favorite rapper growing up was little
keke he's uh Houston h-town hero he grew
up here in Houston he started the style
I'll rap the screwed up style of rap
with look with a little Kiki DJ Screw in
fat Pat you know look he he he always
was my xxx mean screw it up stomp
well DJ Screw he was a DJ born in
Smithville but you know he represented
four here in Houston he created a style
of music where he makes his own mistakes
but he slows the music down he slows the
pitch down a lot and he would take
normal whatever was on regular rap radio
and whatever rap music was in the
streets and he would slow it down and he
would mix it a certain way he would call
chopping and screwing and you know he
created what was kind of screwed up
click where they basically also along
with him creating his own form of
hip-hop in the genre of the hip hop tree
the screwed up style of music he also
created this style of rap where they
would freestyle off the top of their
head and just say whatever comes to
their mind shout out the different
neighborhoods around town or different
friends or whatever you know talk about
who's driving what car those type of
things then they just you know created a
style that's our own here in Houston I
grew up just idolizing that who's the
most influential rapper right now I
would say to me
turn about time I mean I think Tupac
will be the most influential of all time
but right now it definitely has got to
be Kanye West you know do you like yeah
I mean we got a song together
I made grills for him I got a like he's
gonna make you money yeah yeah am I
gonna get a grill oh yeah we got the
grill on ice for you right now ice we
got TV Johnny right now yes what's the
street value of my grill just in case
you know if I'm Alan you know anyone
well you know every every grill is
customized for the individual person for
instance so if if I got raw right now
somebody to my grill is really worthless
to the person the only thing you know
the value of the gold and diamonds does
yeah account for something but most of
the cost in areas on the personalized
hands sitting of each diamond the
diamond settings are pretty expensive
that's where a lot of the cost comes in
how do you do girls for so you did one
for Kanye West yeah we've done I mean
pretty much any rapper anybody that's
affiliated in hip-hop who has grills
almost we've made grills for almost all
of them but you know in the sports world
we've done on foot you know Shaq Venus
and Serena Williams
Carl Crawford we just did some for him
not too long ago Adrian Braun also uh
Miller
yes Super Bowl MVP von Miller we just
known for him so we got President Bush
right no no no reply okay now I came up
with an idea for you yes let's do it
I mean you have a grill yeah and then
you open it up and you can actually cook
on the grill I'm ready to go into
production with you right now
let's go you me and music plays we are
killing it yeah get a sub woofer down
there yeah put some take some wire wheel
two elbows swingers on there yeah ready
whatever you just said yes I have no
idea when you what do people want to
they want to hear you rap when they see
you sometimes sometimes they just want
to see my groupies mouth but do you rap
when somebody ask you like if somebody
said give me something right now well it
just depends on if you know they paid
the proper they
the proper booking procedures you know
comes with a price yeah you know in my
younger days you know it was a little
different would someone say rap and I
would just really give it away
yeah oh oh okay all right fair enough
fair enough so I get a grill now is it
gonna be ready today or I wait till
Monday to put my grilling maybe you'll
be ready by the UH
by the championship game that's what
we're hoping for we're hoping you'll be
ready by the championship game I like
that so I may wear it to the
championship that's very nice
do you play sports I did growing up man
my I have a great tenacity man you know
I'm saying on a hard work ethic man I
got a lot of heart but my uh my uh right
there with you avoid doing Brown always
teased me about not having any athletic
ability Manchester pick chest appears
always clowns me anytime we go to the
celebrity home run derbies you know I'm
not always the one with the big egg or
Billy with zero you know couple ground
balls but not Puckett are you doing a
Houston oiler album yes sir
well Houston all are being the original
football team here for uh
from Houston you know they when they
moved on you know they took a lot of our
hearts we demanded Texans have you know
regained our hearts back and I hope for
you know success in football here in uh
the city of Houston but the Houston
Oilers are something or team that I grew
up you know just watching the fans of
and uh you know they determine all that
means something else too you know law
underground meaning to you know to a
little secret meaning too so you know
you can't go into too much detail you
know when I talk to Kanye later they'll
ask him he'll be talking to me if you
had the DeAngelo Russell swaggy P
situation how would that be handled in
the rap community well you know um jay
printz
CEO rap-a-lot records you know he used
to have a way handling things like that
he would take both the people bring you
to the boxing ring give your boxing
gloves and say don't don't come out of
here till it's settled you know I'm
saying sorry
yeah I take I'll take a page out of Jay
princess book land I've put them in
their box
I said handle this and then wonder so it
still might not be over when they come
out the ring they might need a few
rematches it's great to have you Paul
Paul's gonna fit me for a grill of
course and I guess I'll have it on
Monday a Twitter handle
Paul wall baby yes and Paul wall baby
eight studio albums and of course he's
got one with Kanye but then so do i so
yeah they didn't come out yet
yeah Paul it's great to see you hey
thank you for coming by yes they
appreciate the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience